Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and I just wanted to make a very quick video
on the use of DIM for everybody, including cancer patients, but the purpose of DIM is to
help pull out what we could call bad estrogens.
So bad estrogens are estrogens, metabolites that are made in your body, or Zetoestrogens that
you receive from the environment that could interrupt estrogen metabolism, they can block specific
apoptonic receptor sites on the cell membrane and can be a contributor to cancer and especially
any of the hormone derived cancers that are prostate, breast, uterine, ovarian, etc.
So DIM is a great product to add to your protocol, and it's a product that we've used
for quite a long time.
So we talk about the different types of estrogens, this is a chart that you could look at.
DIM has an action to help pull estrode to two hydroxy-estradial and two hydroxy-esterode.
Those are the protective or what are called maybe the good estrogens.
The 16 hydroxy-esterode and the 4 hydroxy-esterode could be considered the bad estrogens.
Even though in reality there's such big as good or bad here, it has to do with the balance
of those things.
And when we have too many of those 16 and 4 hydroxies, then that can end up causing a problem.
They can disrupt different metabolisms of estrogen, breakdown of estrogen.
It in itself can block a poptonic receptor sites.
Those are the receptor sites needed on the cell membranes to stimulate cell death.
So by themselves they can cause a lot of problems.
So DIM helps decrease the 16 and the 4 hydroxies and increase the 2 hydroxies.
That's really what we want.
So how do we take DIM?
We could buy DIM in a supplement.
We have used DIM alone in a supplement.
So what's the best thing to take?
And the reason for this video is we had some patients ask, why did you change your supplement?
When we did change our supplement, instead of it just being DIM, we added some synergistic
nutrients to it.
So in more of the research, as you look at it, many of these nutrients don't work just
by themselves.
Or I should say, they do work by themselves.
But when you add synergistic herbs to the component, it can help the component to this
case, DIM, work even more effectively.
So with this adaptation of DIM that we put together here, it has some ashwagandha, which
is very good at balancing hormones.
Ashwagandha is considered an adaptogen, along with jinsi and tribulus.
Those are adaptogenic herbs that can help balance estrogen, progesterone, thyroid and adrenal
hormones, and they can work synergistically with DIM.
Bede extract, which is the macuda, is very good for helping with dopamine balance.
Dental extract is an anti-inflammatory, along with long jack.
Grape seed extract is a TH2 stimulator and a little bit of beta hydrochloride for proper digestion
and absorption of these nutrients.
So we tweaked the formula on our product to add these synergistic nutrients, so it would
work better.
So I do know in tweaking the formula, adding these things we lowered the total number of
caps in the product, but we added a lot of beneficial synergistics to this as well.
So I'm very confident that we have a better product than DIM alone.
So that's why we make some changes to some products as data comes out.
We want to constantly be improving so things work better in a person's body.
All right, hopefully that helps.
This product can be found on our website if you look at ConnorsClidic.com and you click on
the store and you search for DIM, DIM, DIM, you'll find this product.
All right, bye-bye.